- My mom was a teacher, my
grandfather was a teacher.
(light string music)
And then we'll be ready to
move on to actually finding
missing angels using our
Khan Academy program.
Myself growing up, '80s, '90s kid,
I was like super into video games,
and I really wanted to
make my own video games.
(upbeat video game voice)
So I got into the computer
programming classes
and it was really cool.
So just based on the
diagram you just figure out.
- Everybody kept saying wow,
you explain things really well,
so I ended up changing my
minor wanted to pursue teaching
full-time.
Ever since then I haven't looked back.
Perfect, nice job guys.
(lively instrumental music)